two days of terror have left dozens dead
in southwestern Mexico on Monday 14
police officers were killed in the state
of Michoacan
the officers were ambushed by gunmen
associated with the Jalisco nueva Haneda
seoane cartel
[Music]
the families of the lawmen blamed
regional leaders for the deaths saying
local police are under equipped to
battle the region's well armed and
highly organized criminal groups
you sent innocent people to their deaths
what didn't she train them to defend
themselves these boys were 18 and 19
years old now they're dead on Tuesday a
gunfight left another 15 dead this time
in the state of Guerrero the incident
involved Mexican soldiers exchanging
gunfire with armed civilians between six
and eight people managed to escape into
the bush we are conducting a sweep in
cooperation with other security forces
deadly incidents like these are becoming
increasingly common in Mexico and add to
the twenty seven thousand four hundred
and seventy eight homicides nationwide
since President and the desmondo a Lopez
over other entered office despite the
escalation in violence the president
insists that advances are being made as
if Alta there's a lack of peace in the
country but we will achieve it however
there is momentum behind this problem it
was allowed to grow for far too long
but we will find a way to resolve it
while a majority of violent deaths are
increasing in only a handful of Mexican
states there has also been in increasing
crimes along with an increase in the
perception of insecurity nationwide in a
national public security poll conducted
by the government in the summer more
than 70 percent of people say they
consider the city they live in
unsafe many here worried 2019 will
shatter all previous records for
homicides nationwide if the current
trend of violence continues that may
just be the case manopoly al jazeera
Mexico City